es gibt einen Kulturkampf der von dieser
Regierung vielleicht nicht angezettelt
aber konsequent weitergeführt wird es
gibt in Berlin diese großartige Stiftung
Preußischer Kultur besetzt die das Erbe
nicht nur Preußen sondern auch andere
Kulturgüter verwaltet das soll jetzt bei
der Umbau dieser Stiftung sollte Begriff
Preußen aus dem Titel genommen werden
weil Preußen wird bei uns immer noch
konnotiert mit Militär und Marschmusik
für mich ist Paris und was anderes das
sind z.B große Reformer für Freiherr von
Stein oder August von Hardenberg die
haben große Reformen durchgesetzt die
noch heute bedeuten sind aber Preußen
muss da raus aus dem Titel der
Kulturstiftung aus Gründen die
vermutlich uns nur Claudia rot erklären
kann und ich glaube auch sie käme in
Argumentation Schwierigkeiten ein
anderes Beispiel wenn Sie mir noch paar
Sekunden können
gut dann muss ich nicht so hetzen nein
überhaupt gut es hat ja vor kurzem das
Treffen der Außenminister der G7 gegeben
in Münster und vermutlich in dem Saal in
dem auch der festfälischer Frieden
verhandelt wurde und vor dem Treffen
wurde ein Kreuz das an der Wand Hink
entfernt entfernt verstehen sie meine
man muss nicht Christ sein schon gar
nicht ein praktizierender aber wir leben
in einer christlich geprägten Kultur und
da wird ein Kreuz abgegangen bei einem
Treffen der Außenminister ohne dass ich
jemand darüber beschwert hätte das
keinen Fall bekannt geworden weil Jude
oder ein Moslem oder eine Atheist sich
darüber beschwert hätte na ja und dann
gab es wirklich das deutsche
durcheinander Frau bärburg die dann die
Konferenzleiter der bedauerte die
Maßnahme und sagte dieser Maßnahme habe
aber sei keine politische sondern nur
eine organisatorische Entscheidung
gewesen ja ja das hat sie wirklich
gesagt das heißt und ich hatte ja dafür
entschuldigt und der spreche das
ausländischen des Auswärtigen Amtes
sagte noch was witziger
es habe eine Veränderung des Mobiliars
gegeben und im Zusammenhang dieser
Veränderung des Mobiliars anderer Tisch
andere Beleuchtung andere Teppiche sagen
das Kreuz sind ja aber es geht noch
weiter nächstes
Ärgernis die Kuppel des Berliner Doms
trägt eine Inschrift die von wie hieß
der noch mal der Kaiser Friedrich
Wilhelm IV 1844
angeordnet wurde ein völlig harmloses
Zitat aus der Bibel ich weiß nicht was
neues oder altes Testament ist es geht
darum dass die Menschen sich in die
Macht Gottes begeben und Claudia Roth
ich tut mir leid dass ich Sie wieder
zitiere aber leider hat sie mein Leben
schon viel zu oft gekreuzt Claudia rot
sagt dieser Spruch dieser Spruch ist
kein unpolitisches Zeichen von
Religiosität oder eine politische
Botschaft die den von Gott abgeleitet
der Herrschaftsanspruch des
Preußenkönigs untermauern es wird von
allem erstmal eine Gefahr oder zumindest
auf die Füße tritt oder sowas ich glaube
das entspricht einfach nicht im Weltbild
ist wie auch in der letzten Fall mit
Münster ist auch in diesem Fall glaube
ich noch keine einzige Beschwerde
eingegangen von einem anderen Gläubigen
und man muss sich vorstellen dass hier
dieses gottesnahmt und wieder beschworen
wird dieser Preußenkönig ist wann ist er
gestorben 1861 aber für Rot lebt er
gleich
immer noch weiter und knechtet uns und
unsere Bekenntnis